ben Murat
o zamanın var mı Bir şey soracağım sana
Şu an vaktim biraz dar Yani eğer uzunsa
istersen sonra konuşalım kısaysa Şimdi
iyiyim seni
yiyeceğim Sence İnsan neden var abi soru
kısaymış da cevabı peki O kadar değil
yani öyle bir soru sormanın zamanı şimdi
ya ne kadar zamansız bir soru oldu bu de
gerçekten de çok zamansız bir soru oldu
Neden derseniz Çünkü bu soruya cevap
verebilecek bir çok farklı Konu başlığı
var peki Sence neden Zamansız oldu
abi şurada Aceleniz var 15-20 Dakika da
konuşmayı bitirmemiz lazım Sence neden
Zamansız oldu e Bence de İnsanın neden
varım diyebilmesi için duygu düşünce
sorgulama sistematiği Bizim Türkümüz
olan homosapien için hiç değişmedi Bence
de o yüzden zamansızdı hatta o
insanların şu anda var olduğunu bilmemiz
için sonraki nesillerde bir şey bırakmış
olmaları gerekir yani bu bir eser
olabilir bir hikaye olabilir bir anı ya
da bir düşünce Sonuçta onlar ve deride
Zamansız yani ölümsüz olanlar değil mi
konu nerelere geldi bir anda Madem öyle
hadi başlayalım malum acelemiz var Evet
acelemiz var bende son dönemde hem iş
hayatında hem sosyal Hayatımda bu
cümleleri sıklıkla duyuyorum Haydi
acelen var çok acele hemen hemen bunu
yapmamız lazım bununla beraber Hiç
Vaktim Yok gün bana yetmiyor ve genel
olarak da bunun bir şikayet hali olarak
dile getirildiğini Hatta insanda bir
genel şikayet hali oluşturulan fark
ediyorum onlardan bir tanesi de benim
mesela online sipariş veriyorum vaktinde
gelmiyor Tabii orada bir vakit aradığı
veriliyor işte bir günde kapımda 30
dakikada miden de
bu Ebu Aralık verildikten sonra hem bu
Vakit aradığını veren firmanın sahibi
hem siparişi veren Ben hem de vaktinde
ulaştırmaya çalışan kuryede Bu bir baskı
oluşturuyor Tabii ki herkes görevini en
iyi şekilde yapmaya çalışıyor e Siparişi
ver olarak ben de sorumluluğumu bilip
evde homurdanır şikayet ediyorum olduğum
yerde Bu arada şikayet kelimesinin
anlamını sözlükten baktığımız zaman
kelimenin yakınmak ve sızlanmak gibi
kavramlarla eş anlamlı olduğunu
görüyoruz Bu kavramlar dayanmak yapmanın
verdiği his ve o yanma sesiyle Aslında
bağlantılı Dolayısıyla şikayet ettiğimiz
de aslında bir anlamıyla dayanıyoruz ve
bu yanmanın acısında hissediyoruz Peki
Kim bu acıyı hissetmek ister ki bu
acıdan nasıl kurtuluruz Belki de şikayet
etmeyerek Hatta senin bir tane anın var
Bununla ilgili bir günün bir evet dedim
kesinlikle Çünkü bu şikayet etme hali
Tabii ki de Şikayet edin en büyük
görmemezlik görmezden gelmek anlamına
gelmemeli söylediğin gibi o büyük de
hastaneye gittiği zaman Doktor ona
soruyor şikayetiniz nedir diye büyüğüm
de şikayetim yok ki Evladım Diyor Doktor
şaşıran gözler defa karşısına Baktığı
zaman yok ki ona şikayetinizi diye
sormayın nereniz ağrıyor diye sorun o
zaman cevap verir işte belki Bizim de
şikayet etmek yerine enerjimiz bu
şikayeti harcamak yerine Belki de
ağrıyan yerimize nasıl iyileştirebiliriz
diye odaklanma ihtiyacımız vardır
Vallahi deminki sipariş örneği mi
saymazsak ben de katılıyorum sana hayat
bu kadar kısayken hele ki bu hız çağında
insan nasıl şikayet etmeye vakit arıyor
anlamıyor ay vakit ayırıyor anlamıyorum
tabi Şaka bir yana konu Hayat olduğunda
gerçekten şikayet etme lüksümüz yok
aslında Evet bazı şeyler beklediğimizin
dışında gerçekleşecek bazı şeyler canın
dışına çıkacak ama işte Tam da bu
süreçlerde ne yapacağımıza karar vermeye
Selam bugün bir firma ile bir eğitim
için anlaştım ve öncesinde bütün
hazırlıkları yaptık işte eğitimin
yapılacağı yer katılımcı sayısı sunumu
yansıtılmış yansıtılacak projeksiyon
vesaire gibi bütün teknik detaylar
eeğitim günü sabah erkenden kalktım ben
de kendi hazırlıklarımı yaptım firmaya
ulaştığımda tam eğitime yarım saat kala
bana projeksiyonun kullanılamayacağı
söylendi bir Eğitmen için en büyük
kabuslarından biridir özellikle eğitimi
bu kadar kısa sürede yapılan
değişiklikler Hele ki konu projeksiyon
gibi eğitimin akışını derinden
etkileyecek bir konuysa Yani şöyle bir
örnek vereyim diyelim ki bilgisayarda
oyun oynuyorsun ama touchpad veya
klavyeyi kullanamıyorsun onunla eşler
Peki şimdi ne yapacağız oyunun atması
lazım herşey hazır ya devam edeceksin ya
da oyunu bırakacaksın Evet belki klavye
yok ama Mouse var
her yerini tutmayabilir ama yine de var
Yeter ki insan devam edebilme
yaklaşımında olsun Ben O eğitime
projeksiyon kullanmadan sadece beyaz
tahtayla verimli şekilde bitirdim Peki
cebime Ne kaldı artık projeksiyon
kullanma zorunluluğu mu rafa kalktı Şu
anda istediğim gibi verebiliyorum
eğitimleri istersem klavye ile istersem
mausla gerçekten şikayet etmek yerine
ağrıyan yerine iyileştirmeye odaklanmış
sın Bu arada sipariş ilgili verdiği
örneği de anlayabiliyorum Sonuçta
teknoloji bizim hayatımızı
kolaylaştırdığı kadar Aslında
zorlaştırabilir your bize zaman
kazandırdığı kadar bazen zamanımızda
çalabiliyor Dolayısıyla teknolojiyle
beraber Aslında konforunuz oldukça arttı
ama işler planın dışına çıktığında da bu
Konfor oldukça etkileniyor Doğrudur
Çünkü her şey Konfor ve rahatlık üzerine
düzenlidir bugün dijital de bize
sağladığı Konfor kadar talep edilip
Sürdürülebilir hale geliyor Hatta Evet
şimdi bebeklerimiz için hiç ou2 kuşağı
diye adlandırılıyor onlar için belki de
ilk Konfor uzaktan kumandayı Hatta
uzaktan kumanda yok Kendi bizdik Yani
senin benim gibi yakışıklı çocukları bu
komut almıştır Hadi kalk bakalım
değiştir Şu kanalı diye Aynen Peki sence
bugün ya da bizim için nedir büyük
Konfor değişimi ev bizim kuşak için
muhtemelen cep telefonu en büyük
değişiklik oldu ve biz ona en başından
bugüne kadar deneyimlemiş olduk Peki her
geçen gün hızlanarak dijitalleşen bu
dünyada bugün nedir Konfor değişimi bu
soruyu nereden sorduğuna bağlı erce
rasyonlar açısından soruyorsan
kimilerine göre dijital ile birlikte
makas kapanmaya başladı kimilerine göre
de dijital ile birlikte makas açılıyor
ama bana göre de insan x-y-z
kuşaklarından bağımsız her zaman aynıydı
Aslına bakarsan bu jenerasyon arasındaki
etkileşimi ve aralarındaki farkı ele
alan konuşmaları yazılı Ne sıklıkla son
dönemde görmeye başladım Özellikle de
bazı çocukların o ekranın içine
doğdukları için onları o içine
doğdukları ekran karşısından almanın
oldukça güç olduğundan bahsediyorlar ve
bu noktada Tabi bu olay hem çocuğun hem
ailesine hayatında birtakım etkilere yol
açıyor teknoloji hayatımızı
kolaylaştırıyor belki ama biraz daha az
hareket etmek belki odaklanma sorunu
yaşamak ya da sosyal ilişkilerde
birtakım zorluklar gibi sorunlara yol
açtığı görülüyor Dolayısıyla Aslında
biraz Bu açıdan sormuştum soruyu yani bu
kadar çok jenerasyon arasındaki farktan
bahsederken senin için nasıl xy&z
jenerasyondan bağımsız hep aynıydı İnsan
ilk Sorduğum soru gibi Aslında insanda
Zamansız En azından Medeniyet Tarihi
dönebilen insan için Çünkü baktığınızda
12 bin yıllık süreçte insana dair hiçbir
şey değişmedi mi insan her zaman
duygusuyla karar alıyordu Bugün de öyle
insan her zaman kendi kabulünü arıyordu
Bugün de öyle insan her zaman çok
görülmek duyulmak onaylanmak istiyordu
Bugün de böyle E peki ne değişti
derseniz Aslında tek bir şey değişti o
da teknoloji Biz isteklerimizi ona
adapte ettik teknoloji ile yaşadığımız
evler değiştim ulaşım halimiz değişti
işlerimiz iş yapış şekillerimiz değişti
iletişim halimiz değişti Hatta gelecek
hayallerimiz bile değişti bir süre önce
doktorluk Mühendislik gibi meslekler
daha öndeyken daha tercih edilir
durumdayken bugün youtuber olmak
insansın olmak onların önüne geçti Tabii
ki bu saydığım meslekleri de aşağı bir
yere konumlandırılacak söylemiyorum
dönem Neyi gerektiriyorsa oraya önem
göstermeli ihtiyacımız var bartar Imm
devrimini reddeden Avcı toplayıcılar
tarihten silindi Sanayi devrimine direnç
gösterenler rekabette geri kaldığı Bugün
de herhangi bir meslekte ilerlemek
istiyorsak başa bu istiyorsak dijital
edilen gösterdiğimizde başarı şansınızı
tehlikeye atmış oluyoruz Tabii burada
dikkat etmesi gereken şeyler var insanın
O da dişsel tuzaklar dişler meslekler
Niye daha çok ilgi görüyor ve tercih
ediliyor Çünkü dışarıdan bakılınca kolay
gözüküyor bir kamera bir ürün bir içerik
hop tamamız
Evet arkadaşlar herhangi bir meslekte
rekabetin önüne geçebilmek için ve
Sürdürülebilir olabilmek için başka
özellikleri de ihtiyaç var ve Belki de
bu özelliklerden bir tanesi hatta belki
de en önemlisi Neyse ki çok uzaklarda
aramaya gerek yok Hemen şurada Gönlümüz
Peki nedir Gönül Bununla ilgili çok
güzel bir hikaye vardır aklına gelen
bütün bilgiler haydi bize bir bilmece
gibi çöz derler Neden bir bilmece gibi
Çünkü göz belli bir mesafe ötesini
göremez kulak belli bir frekansı üstüne
altını işitemez his ise belli bir
sıcaklık ötesine idrak bile edemez Bir
de üstüne üstlük bütün bu Duygulardan
gelen bilgiler hafıza dediğimiz önceden
Yaşadıklarımıza takılıp bütün eksikleri
ve yanlışlıkla orada kalırlar
akıllınokta der ki ben Acizim ve bu
bilmeceyi çözemiyorum ve işte bu noktada
akıl gönlüne başvurur Şair ne demiş akıl
Akıl olsaydı adına Gönül derlerdi ki bu
kültüre baktığımız zamanda da gönlün
hiçbir şeyle ölçülemeyecek kadar yüce
olduğundan bahsedilir Hatta bu noktada
gönül gözü de devreye girer ve insanın
hakikati ancak gönül gözüyle
görebileceğim söylenir Bunun nedeni
Belki de aklın zıtlıklar üzerine
işletmesidir Tıpkı teknolojinin bize
sunduğu birler ve sıfırlar gibi akıl
güzeli görmeden çirkin anlayamaz zengini
görmeden fakir anlayamaz bu noktada
Belki de başka bir neden de şairin Başka
Bir şaire şu sözü nedir akıl Bender
Gönül Sender Sokrates'in onu
dinleyenlere gözlerini gökyüzüne çevirip
yıldızların hareketlerini ve dünya
olaylarını araştırıp bilgilerini
derinleştirmek önce kendi kalplerine
bakmadan tavsiye ettiği bilinmektedir
platon'da onu dinleyenler şunu
söylemiştir yüksek bilgiler kitaplarda
bulunmaz insan onları kendi vicdanı
hazinesinden derin araştırma ve
düşüncelerle çıkarmalıdır Mevlana
hazretleri izah Bu çok güzel bir söz
vardır gönlün içinde kelimeler ihtiyaç
duymayan bir ses var dinle ve ekler
bazen aynı dili konuşan insanlar
anlaşamaz Ken farklı dili konuşan
insanlar Gönül dili anlaşabilirler işte
Bence bu tarihi İz Bırakanlar Zamansız
olanlar kendilerine gönüllerini ortaya
koydular kesinlikle Peki biz bunları
nasıl biliyoruz Çünkü bu gönüllerini
ortaya koyan insanlar bize bu bilgi
mirasını bıraktılar hatta sadece
gönüllerini değil bulundukları ortamın
çevreye Hatta Çağ'a değer katarak
Zamansız aştılar Yani ölümsüzleştirdiler
bir değerler insanlar için çok önemli
kavramlardan bir tanesi Hani dedim ya
Konuşmanın ortasında İnsan kendi
kabulünü arıyor diye işte Belki de bu
kabuldeki en büyük tatmini kendi
değerini hayata kalktığında deneyin
diyor işte bunlardan bir tanesi de kendi
kabulünü felsefede bulmuş Bu benim için
çok özel bir yeri olan epik de tospik
tospik ve felsefenin önemli
temsilcilerinden bir tanesi su acılık
genel olarak dışarıda olanlara değil
dışarıda olanların içimizdeki etkisini
odaklanan bir felsefi yaklaşım bunun
yanında dışarı yönetmeye Çalışmak yerine
içimizi yönetmeye çalışmayı öğütleyen
bir öğretim ve epiktetos tarih boyunca
bu öğreti ile bir çok alana değer katmış
ve şimdi paylaşacağım sözüyle bu
Konuşmaya değer katmaya devam edecek
Zamanımız çok az ve Yapacak çok işimiz
var aslında Ne kadar basit ama bir o
kadar da hepimizi ilgilendiren bir söz
peki buradan bu kadar Yapacak çok şey
varken mı sence hangi değeri en çok
ihtiyaç var o ağabey Bence Listenin
başında gayret geliyor Çünkü Her işin
başı niyettir derler ve bu niyetin
ortaya çıkması için gayret gerekir Bu
gayret daha sonra harekete dönüşür ve
harekette bereket vardır bunu şu örnekle
anlatabilirim bir elma çekirdeği düşünün
içinde elmanın bütün potansiyeli
mevcuttur ama potansiyeli ortaya çıkması
gayreti gerektirir o tohumun ekilmesi
sulanması onunla ilgilenmesi gerekir ve
İşte o zaman elmanın potansiyeli ortaya
çıkar meyve oluşur Dolayısıyla Bereket
oluşur işte bu noktada Belki de önemli
bir de Tak bu gayretin istikrarlı bir
gayret olması gerekir yani kararlı ve
devamlı yani tohumu bir kere Ekip Bir
kere sulamak yetmez onunla kararlı ve
devamlı bir şekilde ilgilenmek ona
bakmak gerekir ve böylece de görüyoruz
ki aslında
Allah bereket olmayan bir gayret yoktur
Bunu da Nelson Mandela'nın çok sevdiğim
bir sözü var onunla belki
açıklayabilirim kendisi der ki ben
hiçbir zaman kaybetmem ya kazanırım ya
ders alır öğrenirim işte gayretini
sonucu ne olursa olsun bu sonuncu bir
ders bir öğreti olarak gören insan yol
alır ve ilerler ve biz de görüyoruz ki
tarihe İz Bırakanlar yol alanlar gayret
edenlerdir Peki sen hangi dine sahip
çıkıyorsun İzzet ben sürekli
sorgulayarak özgürlüğüne sahip çıkmaya
çalışıyorum beni bu özgürlükten alıkoyan
duygu ve düşünce kalıplarını yıkmaya
çalışarak Çünkü biliyorum ki özgürlük
sanılanın aksine dışarıda olan bir
kavram değil özgürlük tamamen iç
huzurunuza bağlantılı bir kavramdır
şartları çok yerinde olan ama içsel
huzur olmayan kişi bu hayatında kayboluş
yaş aramadı şartlarından bağımsız içsel
huzurun yakalamış kişide bu hayatta ne
olur ve bu hayatta kendini bulmaktan
daha önemli çok az şey vardır Bence de
kendini bulmak çok önemli Biz kendimizi
bulabilir miyiz Umarım ama bununla
ilgili çok sevdiğim söz vardır arayarak
bulunmaz ama bulanlar arayanlardır
kendini bulma yolculuğunda Belki de
insan önce bilmediğini bilmelidir Çünkü
bildiğini zanneden kişi bulduğunu
zanneder bulduğunu zannettiği içinde
aramaz ama bilmediğini bilen kişi bulmak
için aramaya gayret eder Benim de kendi
hayatımda bu bilmediğimi fark ettim
küçük bir an olmuştu Bir açık hava
aktivitesi düzenliyorum ve Mayıs ayında
gerçekleşecek bu aktivite Yağmur
açısından riski dönem olduğu için ben
ayrı öncesinden dua etmeye başlamıştık
Ne oldu Yağmur yağmasın diye o gün geldi
ve alana binlerce kişi geldi Hatta
beklediğimizin çok üstünde kişi geldi ve
tam bir kaos oluştu o kaos'un tam Zirve
yaptığı noktada bardaktan boşalırcasına
yağmur yağmaya başladı ve alandan bu o
ayrıldı ve gerçekten orada kalması
gereken kişi kadar insan kaldı orada ve
biz aktiviteyi tamamladık Çünkü Yağmurun
ardından da güneş açtı çok başarılı
taklit iyiydi ama orada ben biraz
Aslında fark ettim ki benim Aylar
Boyunca yağmasın Hayır hayır yağmasın
dediğim Yağmur Aslı benim için çok büyük
bir Hayırdır dolayısıyla biraz oda fark
etti gerçekten her şeyde bir hayır
vardır Tabii bu bakış açısı insana çok
olumlu bir duruş kazandırıyor O yüzden
de bana genelde Yağmur Adam hep bardağın
dolu tarafını görüyorsun derdin ama
bence tam böyle değil Çünkü İzzet sağ
olsun Bana belgesel önermişti yumun
aldığı belgeselde çok güzel bir sahne
vardır ölüm döşeğinde olan dedesine
torunu gider ki Dedeciğim ne kadar güzel
bir hayat yaşadın hep olumlu tarafı
gördüm Senin için bardak hep doluydu
bardağın hep dolu tarafını gördüm de der
ki oğlum baksana bardak güzel işte Bence
hayatı böyle değerlendirmek lazım dolu
yada boş var ama orada bir bardak var ve
bardağı Bir Hayal etsenize o bardağı
oluşturan kum taneleri yüksek kısmının
altında uzun süreçlerden geçerek su gibi
şeffaf taş gibi sarar aslında bir
noktada mucizevi bir cisim oluşturmuş
işte Bence insan Hayata da böyle biraz
bakmalı ve bu bakış açısına sahip olan
insanda bence zamansızdır Çünkü artık o
yüzden için zaman yoktur o insan için
kıymetini bileceği birbirinden eşsiz ve
değerli anlar vardı Sadece
harika Sonuç olarak Zamansız insanı
paylaştık sizinle hem Evrensel duasını
hem bugünkü acele sini hem de ölümsüz
halinin Peki Bütün bunlar dahilinde Sen
ne yapmak istiyorsun nereden geldiğini
biliyor muyum yani Evrensel Doğan'ı Şu
anda neredeyim yani şikayet mi ediyorsun
yoksa yoluna devam ediyorsun ve nereye
gidiyorum yani yolculuğunda hangi
değerlere sahip çıkacaksın Çok
teşekkürler Ha